get ready to slay zombies monsters and
the beat with January's PlayStation Plus
extra and premium editions the PS5
upgrade of Devil May Cry 5 the special
edition headlines the new offerings
which boasts improved graphics and more
challenging gameplay modes as well as
some additional story content other
additions to the PS plus Library include
popular anime fighting games Dragon Ball
fighter Z left for dead spiritual
successor back for blood and the
critically acclaimed episodic Adventures
life is strange and life is strange
Before the Storm jet to the far Shore is
an Interstellar trip across the cosmos
with a unique soundtrack that creates a
meditative experience and just cause 4
reloaded is a pretty decent sandbox in
which you explosively topple a corrupt
regime if you'd prefer a more cerebral
change of pace Erica is worth trying out
a live action and interactive Thriller
Erica mixes murder childhood trauma and
grisly detective work together to to
create a gripping narrative for retro
fans the PlayStation classics coming for
premium subscribers include an enhanced
version of siphon filter 3 destructive
racing and Star Wars Demolition and Hot
Shots Golf 2. each one of these games
has been updated with quality of life
features such as enhanced up rendering
rewind quicksave and custom video
filters PlayStation Plus members can
also grab the free games for January's
essential tier which include Star Wars
Jedi Fallen order Axiom Verge 2 and
Fallout 76 a full list of all games
coming to PS plus this month can be
found at gamespot.com from PlayStation
to Xbox the rumored developer direct for
Microsoft's console has been confirmed
for January 25th the event will Center
on the Elder Scrolls Online Forza
Motorsport Minecraft Legends and redfall
with quote big features and extended
gameplay showcases on those titles
according to Xbox wire if you're
wondering about Starfield Microsoft says
a standalone show in the future will
focus on the title from Bethesda game
studios this detail was also a part of
the original rumor of the developer
direct earlier this week speaking of
Xbox it seems that we might get some
more news soon on when we can expect
ubisoft's Subscription Service Ubisoft
plus to come to the platform speculation
has arisen after several Ubisoft games
have been marked as free in the Xbox
store's back end as discovered by
Twitter user Moro NL Ubisoft plus coming
to Xbox was announced almost exactly one
year ago to the day by the mega
publisher so its potential imminent
release is a long time coming no word on
whether this would exist as a separate
subscription or be bundled in with Xbox
game pass ultimate but if it were to be
the latter expect your ultimate
subscription cost to rise as both it and
ubsoft plus cost 15 a month Ubisoft news
doesn't stop there though in a statement
from the company it reveals that it has
canceled three unannounced games and has
delayed Skull and Bones yet again with
Ubisoft stating recent launches have not
formed as well as expected Ubisoft CEO
Yves Gilmore specifically calls out
Mario plus rabid Sparks of Hope one of
gamespot's top 10 best of 2022 and Just
Dance 2023 as underperformers all you
watching that didn't play Sparks of Hope
how could you and yes stop me if you've
heard it before but Skull and Bones has
been delayed again no it is not April
the 1st the game originally slated to be
released in 2018 got delayed to 2019
then 2022 at which point it was
announced that the scope of the project
had been changed resulting in further
delays to 2021 and finally 202 or got a
release date of November 8th last year
mere months before that date however it
got pushed to March 9th of 2023 and is
now once again in limbo for some time
between April 1st 2023 and April 1st
2024. who wants to bet it hits that
window what games are you looking
forward to hearing more about the Xbox
developer direct what guest do you have
for Skull and Bones then Central release
date it's got to come out at some point
right let us know in the comments and
we'll see you here for more Gamespot
news
[Music]